Exacto un resultado que no sorprende a
nadie como bien lo mencionabais 53 votos
a favor 91 abstenciones y 201 votos en
contra no habrá por lo tanto elecciones
generales anticipadas que era el
principal objetivo de esta moción de
censura fueron muchas horas de debate
sin ninguna propuesta concreta Y es que
en la Constitución española la moción de
censura tiene que ser constructiva es
decir tiene que haber una propuesta de
un candidato que si lo hubo pero una
propuesta de un programa conciso de
gobierno alternativo Y eso no existió 14
horas de debates en el parlamento con
exposiciones o con
discursos muy largos algo que molestó
profundamente al candidato de 89 años
Ramón tamames es militante del partido
comunista y ahora candidato por la
ultraderecha que pidió que no responder
a ninguno de los grupos parlamentarios
para no alargar más el debate solo
respondió al presidente del gobierno
Pedro Sánchez y a la vicepresidenta del
gobierno la segunda vicepresidenta
Yolanda Díaz En definitiva como bien lo
mencionabas también fue una moción de
censura La que puso en el gobierno en
2018 a Pedro Sánchez y es una nueva
moción de censura esta vez fracasada que
ha dado la oportunidad en 2023 a Pedro
Sánchez y a todo el gobierno para
exponer los logros en avances sociales
en estos cinco años de legislatura y
para recordar que el partido popular el
mayor de la oposición con su abstención
ha dejado la puerta abierta para una
posible coalición de gobierno con el
partido de ultraderecha vox en las
próximas elecciones generales previstas
para finales de año algo que reprocha el
partido socialista y los socios de
coalición muchos de los grupos
parlamentarios que expusieron sus
razones para abstenerse o rechazar la
moción de censura recordaron que
finalmente no ha sido una moción de
censura en la que va a terminar con esta
legislatura pero que serán los votos de
los ciudadanos quienes decidan si el
mandato de Pedro Sánchez termina este
año o continúa